dr. Saba dr. grubs and dr. Schaack I
have briefly described your basic
research it has led to the efficient
metastasis catalysts that have become
such revolutionary general tools in
organic synthesis and that has changed
our thinking about how to make molecules
your achievements not only make it easy
to answer the question to what youth
science can be put
they are also entirely in the spirit of
Alfred Nobel
sherry Monsieur track safety may
felicitous on the pre-release unsecured
Monde appreciation le prix perform the
about Cabo on behalf of the Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences I wish to
convey our warmest congratulations to
you and I ask you to step forward to
receive the Nobel Prize from the hands
of His Majesty the King
you